alright boys let's wrap it up with a
little debate club all right daddy both
[ __ ] man I've learned a lot I think
actually I don't
well we learned how many rats are what
else did we learn Oh Stephen King wrote
Shawshank
yep the cat in the bugs the tree hat the
bug okay all right with rice that
imagine dinner go to lunch and she's
like where's the restaurant you're like
right here just pimp move let's hit on a
birch and then just boom two bowls of
white rice mm-hmm you're gonna earn it
today girl it's beautiful
no this is this is mother nature there's
something beautiful about that there is
there's something beautiful about the
having a couple bugs with a friend first
we got Dan Weaver from Alexandria
Louisiana gang brother here for Pope
what's up Theo what's up Brendan
I'll see be honest with you guys your
podcast is the best one out there in the
world makes me laugh the most have any
podcast I've ever listened to thanks
Daniel but I got a debate club question
for you who wins out of a hippopotamus
mm or that big old elephant hitter mmm
she in my opinion elephant wins 99.99
percent at the time but let's see what
you guys think
pinky rein fuzz rug let's go
oh this rug dog fuzz Road I have a pet
peeve I think when people say 99.99% of
the time I got it when you said 99% yeah
they keep going it just and it's nothing
against you man has nothing to do with
you
you let my problem hmm so I'm sorry for
thinking that about you cuz stop that 99
so I went the world is a vampire done
yeah I went down
and too much too much I knew it I knew
it I know it when I when I was coming on
my mouth Daniel has that timothy mcveigh
beard piece to man he's got that bomber
bra this dude no you know what I'm
saying this dude Fitzpatrick he looks
very Fitzpatrick quarterbacked yeah yeah
he has every right that's a good that's
what I'm Patrick very Ryan fits yeah you
went dark without school he's that
come-from-behind guy dude this guy'll
get it done bro he's that dude who's
gonna throw for five hundred yards but
never win a game but one game throw for
seven touchdowns but and not win yeah
just put on all these shitty team yeah
calling out he's also a Harvard graduate
I think yeah yeah smart dude shoutout uh
Alexandria Louisiana over there I went
to a prom up there with a girl from Fort
Polk one time and her dad made us watch
while we kissed each other at the end of
the night the dad Watts yeah cuz you
don't want too much tongue in his girl I
don't know yeah that's exactly it you
know pretty easy he wants from pretty
close to he started off kind of farther
when then he got close he was like Joe
Rogan the Wayans bro don't worry am I
gonna hit her yeah just like the way is
bro yeah man let your Wayans brothers
he's primary concern we're gonna slip a
hand on that tip oh yeah well let's go
oh that man yeah he was how old was she
he was in the military and she was uh
she was underage and so was I you're
sixteen sixteen or seventeen yeah well
she one of those sixty or seventy nose
with big old fun bags
cuz that's probably why you saw it I
can't think about that right now dude
it's illegal to think about children
with tits not when you're both seventeen
but I can't be seventeen right now good
point you're going my bad man cuz that's
why the dad so on it you know yeah
that's true if your daughters set a fun
bags you don't anyone flapping those
things around oh I can't imagine if my
daughter has tits dude we're gonna have
to have a talk
stay here you can go out but the tits
stay at the house I know after midnight
good so I'm gonna wrap these things real
tight oh yeah I'm a duct tape those tits
down boy gots to oh man you better shut
it inside yeah
oh she has any nipples dude because I'm
not this stuff's got to stop dude that's
more of a curse than anything having
nipples that are in ease no those are
whatever I'm talking about when you're a
young girl and you're in middle school
or high school and you got you're the
first one to blossom some tits I'm
[ __ ] body Rock it's broken orbs
breath and flesh [ __ ] hitters out the
front cat did you did you know anyone
with that problem we had a girl named
Danielle and man I felt bad for she'd
wear overalls and they would just pop
pow you know I'm saying your overall she
wore overalls you know whoever was they
called him big titty oh yeah she hit too
early man yeah I knew a girl named
Michelle in sixth grade she was fully
endowed like a grown ass yeah and nobody
in her family to make tater Michelle Oh
sometimes Wendy Williams yeah keep going
no one told her that she needed to start
wearing a bra and it got to the point
where a teacher had to go up to her and
tell her that she needed to go home no
more mom to buy her a bra she freaked
out and started crying
oh yeah Brendon well Vic I grade Brendan
wait till she gets at least to eighth
grade I felt bad for those girls cuz I
couldn't wait to walk past her in sixth
period oh there comes tip McGee and then
we didn't say Scribus boner you don't
know what to do dude I get my sweats all
right yeah give it to your friend hold
like hey bro put this here well let's
see your book bags man won't go it
seemed won't leave me alone I'm in
trouble with these double D's dang and
you're crying I'm so they're wet that's
their sexier but we gotta quit talking
about this kind of stuff yeah you're
right so what's this guy want hippos
what hippos versus Hornets young fella
for your clothes I did help us all date
you know no I'm gonna get you another
thing you know hippos kill more people
than any other animal in the world
mm-hmm they're most dangerous animals on
earth hippos are [ __ ] filthy
they're super aggressive and hippos got
that value up top man they got that uh
oh that's rhinoceros yeah oh [ __ ] hippos
man nah the hippos [ __ ] tusks bro and
they live in the water
and you see their little ears like this
in the water net you know done do
they're under this that's an underbite
brain and I'm over it man I think I
think these hippos they sound good but
they also seem like um they're not doing
that good yeah it could be like a high
beast thing you know like High boys hype
hippos yeah people are like oh they're
amazing you get there and they're like
ah yeah it's a great [ __ ] elephant
without a tusk yeah yeah I'm thinking
more they're like the short bus of
elephants really I'm a timeout on hippos
man I'm gonna say elephants
I've always want to feel an elephant's
trunk though 58% elephant not working
well ha player you know I'm saying
Britain looks like the kind of guy that
always wanted to feel an elephant's
trunk hold on with one hand or two hands
I just wanna dump them like this oh yeah
I just want to wring his little nose
that you're gonna get I guess I'm just
like feel a mommy dude I love elephants
why you make it all sexual dude um no I
just drunk and wrap it around like Oh
crazy man what else we got you get some
rest
Matt doors last one this is big man oh
wow what happened he had a vaping
accident
ditches or glue what you think was just
cut the knee open in a car accident
we're here somebody out here yeah no
hear me out here wasn't think cartilage
or bone we got a car accident and he
wants no stitches Lulu hmm you gotta go
fix that could both brothers went that
part of a bone sticking out I mean I
tell you don't want for sure staff you
know what that doesn't look that bad
seems like his necks more the issue that
in yeah do you know [ __ ] up neck
there's nothing you got a neck brace on
kind of car we drive we it's a civic STI
with a fin on the back bro he's about to
get an STI do from the hawk attack he
was gonna get a UTI in that cut he looks
like a vagina you see it was rough I'm
not as Michigan Wolverine neck brace wow
man look man first of all I hope you're
doing healthy you got the heart monitors
and stuff on obviously you know I
thought this was a vaping accident so
I'm glad to know that that's not what
occurred yeah the youth is really into
it and you got to do it if you're
running fast or something you got to be
careful if you're driving a car he said
it was a car car accident I don't know
if I believe that I'm with you I think I
think he was in a vaping act and
watching yuphoria these kids these days
bro well he's not doing real well man he
caught his leg open and there was no
stitches or glue I do both just double
down bro yeah Oh at this point man
you're already not doing that great so I
would not take any chances with
continuing to not do great but I'd also
pretend I'm always search so I get more
painkillers that's why that's not gonna
help that you're gonna end up addicted
to those bro and then you're gonna be
getting in war car accident you're gonna
be sitting in even more questionable
videos like liver or kidney which one do
i donate you know which one do i sell in
the black
so I think it's safety first man I think
you should definitely start taking care
of yourself I would glue I glue
everything bro I glue that [ __ ] and then
also double up with the stitches on top
yeah and I have a friend drive from now
on man I take it easy for a little bit
just take the brakes off yourself ask
other people for suggestions on how to
live your own life
uber like you're doing right now yeah
listen to us
uber uber with your heart broad look for
the Lord bro uber that Nick brought good
luck dog gang bro 71% went with stitches
on that boys and definitely stitches
they can't glue your damn legs crazy
[ __ ] put a zipper on it 2019 man
put the [ __ ] metal zipper on that
[ __ ] this ain't red red plus blue makes
green steel bro you got it you got a
really batten down the hatches this is
your damn limb
[Music]
the King nothing
[Music]